[音楽]
こんにちははじめしゃちょーですちょっと
今日は風が強いなだがこんな日こそ
旅がしたくなる今日の動画は
島に行って
島の人が全員怖かったらどうするの
はいということで私今ですね新潟県の
淡島という島に今から行こうと思ってます
島といえばそう私はじめしゃちょーが一緒
に作らせてもらってます
リリースしましたおめでとうございます
相当クオリティの高い面白いゲームになっ
てるのでマジで1回遊んで欲しいんです
けども今日はそんな神中島の実は舞台にも
なってるような島淡島っていう島があるん
ですけどもそこに後輩2人連れて今から
旅行しに行こうと思ってますでもうね船も
到着してそろそろ出発するんですけれども
なんかね僕の勝手なイメージなんですけど
も
島の人達ってなんか優しいイメージがある
のよ優しくて暖かくてこうなんか島に来て
くれる人を優しく迎えてくれるイメージも
あるんですけどもこの反面ゲームとか
アニメで出てくるそういうなんか
ちっちゃい島って
島の外から来た人にめっちゃ厳しいみたい
なイメージがあるんですけども今回
島全体
淡島に協力していただきまして
島の人間みんな
怖いです
ターゲットだけに僕とかは大丈夫なんです
けども今回僕と健介っていう後輩とサー
ベっていう後輩3人で来てるんですけども
澤辺だけに
島の人間が超怖いです僕としてるんです
けどもターゲットの澤部は全く知らずに
普通になんか今から島に旅行に来て淡島
楽しいぜみたいな感じで来てるんでそんな
ちょっとゲームってわけじゃないんです
けども今から行く島がやばい島で超怖かっ
たらどう思っちゃうのかどういう反応し
ちゃうのかちょっと見ていきたいと思い
ます本当にあの島全体で全面協力して
ちょっとドッキリで仕掛けでやばい島に今
なっちゃってるんで早速手に乗っていき
たいと思いますでは行こう
どうも
健介さん
頑張るよいやもう余裕ですよ何があっても
笑っちゃいけないかというわけで粟島に
行きたいと思います結構しっかりでかい船
だね
ターゲットはもう乗ってます
出航を待ちましょうか
[音楽]
[拍手]
出発したぞー
どこへ向かってるのか分かりません
淡島よ
[音楽]
いい音楽だね
やばい
寄ってきたと思ったら自分にだった今です
ねこの船に
淡島の村長さんもいらっしゃるということ
でちょっとお話ししたいと思いますはいと
いうわけで全ての中が失礼します
淡島の
村長さんですよろしくお願いします
よろしくお願いしますよろしくお願いし
ますこんな
企画大丈夫ですか
ぜひよろしくお願いします皆さんすごく
いい人なのでそれだけ皆さんの勘違いし
ないようによろしくお願いします
勘違い
優しいの逆に今日はもうめちゃくちゃ怖く
島の部外者が来たかのようにやばい
島を演出していただけるとやばいやばい
村長がね協力していただけるのねでかいよ
なかなかそんな大規模で
島で協力していただけることなんてないの
で今日は1日よろしくお願いしますこちら
こそよろしくお願いしますはいということ
で淡島到着しました
降りていきましょうか
すごい
見覚えのあるやつがいるけど
マックなのか
ここの島の人
楽しみあんまりその島に行くこととか俺
ないから結構楽しみなんですよ今日案内し
てくれるんですかはいもちろんです
楽しみ
めっちゃ詳しい
1番の見所は一番この
船です
[音楽]
[拍手]
案内してくれるということよろしくお願い
しますお願いします
天気いいですね今日すごい
最初ってちなみにどこ最初はあの
展望台を行こうかなと
展望台
すごいいい
夕日が見える
綺麗なところがあるんですけど
眺めが良くて今日とかは多分茶道まで
見えるんじゃないかなるほど
ちょうど夕暮れ時なので着れそうねそう
ですねいい感じだと思いますありがとう
ございます早速お願いします
ここは大丈夫ですか
[音楽]
お願いしますか
展望台だ
どうさーで今んとこいいですね今んとこは
ね今のところ
めっちゃいいまだわかんないからねまだ
わかんないから外周
走ってる感じが俺もさ話は聞いてたんだ
けど
具体的に何がこのすごいとかあんまり聞か
ずに来ちゃったからそれを今日逆に3人で
探したいね
回っていきたいと思います
ここが
すごいここが展望台です行きますかお願い
します
すごい
めっちゃ綺麗
もうここが一番
綺麗です
展望台すごいよ
めっちゃいい笑顔はいチーズ
[音楽]
めっちゃいいですね
行きますか
名前だけ聞いてなかったんで一応名前だけ
よろしくお願いします
[音楽]
やばいね
いつものさ雨のボケができないねちょっと
あいつなんだ
めっちゃ綺麗だったね
[音楽]
すごいここはあの
牧場です
牧場なんです
スタッフの方ご紹介するのでありがとう
ございます少し餌やり体験とかもやって
いただこうかなと
牧場スタッフの
村上さんです
[音楽]
ニンジンあげるぽいけど食う
まっすぐなんでちょっとやらせてもらえる
と
案内をお願いします
[音楽]
よしこれこのままで大丈夫です
はい
[音楽]
じゃあ外します
こんな近距離で初めて馬見た
ですけど親が
馬なんですよ
ちょっと同族からのご飯でどう感じてるか
な
[拍手]
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
次行きたいと思います
ね
[音楽]
このアングルでも結構やんちゃ感伝わるね
これがお母さん
健介も
なんでここにいる
深いこと書いてあるよやっておいてよかっ
たやっておけばよかった
大丈夫です行きましょうか
近いね
めっちゃ綺麗
バイバイ
[音楽]
よしお土産お土産
がじゃがいもとかじゃがいもなんです結構
美味しいと言われている
最近はカルビーさんとコラボしてミーの
そら豆のこれを合わせます
作ってるんだ
バカ高いです
[音楽]
けど
えこの人県民性みんな強めなんですか
[音楽]
ここが食堂
パパに名物なんですちょっと今日じゃなく
て別の名物があるんで今日はねちょっと
そっちをご紹介したいなありがとうござい
ます
すごいいい感じの
3人ですか
ありがとうございます
そうですね本当はわっぱにを食べて欲しい
んですけど作るのに結構1時間ぐらい
かかっちゃうんで
今だってやっぱりカレーですかね
ミニカレーみたいな感じで
[音楽]
時間切れ最高
本当は本当は
最悪
怖い普通に
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
ありがとうございますうまそう
淡島カレーいただきますいただきます
[音楽]
うんうまいよ
信じ頼んでごめんはい
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
どうでもいいぐらい怖いんだけど
[音楽]
これ
じゃないです
[音楽]
店長最高にスパイシーです
お疲れ様でした
はいというわけで美味しいからいただき
ました
美味しかった
美味しかったおいしかったです
[音楽]
ということで
合わせていただけるんですか特別に
村長もぜひ会いたいと思います
[音楽]
はいというわけで着きました
淡島うらむら総合庁舎ですここに
村長がいらっしゃるということでちょっと
案内してもらいますお願いしますお願いし
ます
350人なんです人口350人その頂点に
来る人生の男はそうです
[音楽]
ありがとうございます
本当ですか
逆に言いました
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
それでいくら
1500円です
か125円
[音楽]
はい
ドッキリでした
はいというわけでですねそもそも無理して
いただいてちょっと悪役に消していただい
たんですけども
今日このために早く帰ってきたんだよ
みんな変じゃなかった
変でしたとても
島の人全員悪いやつだったらっていう動画
でした
行きたくないです
最初のくだりもそういう感じだと
思う人です
[音楽]